Are you recording?
The question of the moment is, how is the
tragic passing of Justice Scalia going to
affect the 2016 race?
And there are two possible ways of looking
at it, sort of the difference between "is"
and "ought".
It ought to have a profound effect on the
2016 race.
It ought to be disqualifying for certain candidates,
particularly people like Donald Trump, who
give no evidence that they take the Constitution
particularly seriously.
How it is affecting the 2016 race kind of
remains to be seen.
It certainly helps Ted Cruz, who has got a
very good brand in constitutional issues,
knows the Supreme Court well.
It helps Marco Rubio to a lesser extent.
But what it does do for both sides is it heightens
the stakes.
Everybody recognizes now that the future of
the Supreme Court essentially depends upon
this next presidential election.
It will almost surely create a much uglier
political environment because the fight on
Capitol Hill is going to be bleeding into
the presidential race, and vice versa.
So, what are your thoughts on Justice Scalia?
Let us know in the Comments, and also let
us know if there are any other topics that
you'd like us to cover in 60 seconds.